in the most coincidental of swamp
filling coincidences longtime
billionaire Trump adviser Carl Icahn who
literally looks like the evil CEO from
the mr. robot TV series has received a
convenient and lovely exemption from
having to buy federal credits for the
polluting activities of a refinery held
by CVR Energy a company that he owns and
back in August Icahn was very actively
lobbying against this law and the US
Environmental Protection Agency run of
course by none other than Scott Pruett
has granted CVR Energy a financial
hardship waiver now Carl Icahn already
had to resign because of some really
good investigative journalism that
exposed that he was involved in all
sorts of corrupt activity and not only
is Carl Icahn getting a waiver the guy's
worth more than 17 billion and his
company is getting a financial hardship
waiver now I'm gonna explain to you how
this all works but the optics of a
friend of Trump worth 17 billion getting
a waiver for financial hardship is
laughable at its face but I don't know I
guess if you believe in trickle-down
economics if you don't help the guy with
the 17 billion how is it all gonna
trickle down to everybody else right
privatize the losses I'm sorry
socialize the losses and privatize the
gains I've talked about that before
right the profits from CVR Energy don't
go to everybody but the circumstances
that they are calling a financial
hardship will be paid for by exempting
the company from having to buy federal
credits which would become part of the
government's inflows of money that
support our country and everything that
goes into it including infrastructure
this is the same Republican Party by the
way that says we should have total free
markets and the government shouldn't
pick winners and losers but wouldn't the
free market dictate here that they
shouldn't get this financial hardship
waiver and that everybody should just
have to pay for the credits well no
maybe not they're gonna bail out
specific specific companies and I think
this is where the details really matter
right these waivers aren't just
available to companies owned by Trump's
advice
the waivers are made available to all
refineries producing under 75 thousand
barrels of oil per day and just because
you qualify for a waiver you're not
guaranteed to get the waiver it just so
happens that CV R says the refinery in
question produces seventy four thousand
five hundred barrels a day the limit is
75 thousand to qualify for the waiver
they produce seventy four thousand five
hundred that is something that is
commonly done in the industry so of
course there is a foundation for this
type of waiver and the size of refinery
is one that qualifies for it but once
again they got the waiver not everybody
does and Carl Icahn is just the luckiest
guy in the world right this is the same
guy remember Pat when we did the story
about Trump steel tariffs oh yeah and we
found out that just a few weeks before
Carl Icahn had started selling off
massive quantities of steel stock after
not selling any for three years
amazingly lucky that then Trump
announced steel tariffs and the stock
prices on those steel companies crashed
just once again Carl Icahn the luckiest
guy in the world he should be in Vegas
gambling at this point except it's not
gambling that's exactly the point it's
not luck and it's not gambling it is the
swamp filling cronyism that supposedly
Trump said he was gonna do away with
absolutely pathetic today's program is
made possible in part by wink spelled WI
and si I like wine but I don't really
know how to select a bottle of wine and
that's what wink does wink makes it easy
to discover great wines that most
importantly you will like because every
month they ship you wines match to your
tastes and personalized to you now you
might be saying well hold on how do they
know what I will like very good question
you go to their website you go to try
wink comm slash Pakman and you fill out
this very short palate profile quiz they
will ask you questions such as how do
you like your coffee
do you like raspberries or blueberries
and based on the answers to those and a
few other questions
you will get great wines personalized to
you
and delivered right to your door as you
drink more wine which I know many in our
audience do and you rate more bottles of
wine wink learns and you get even more
personalized delicious wines for next
time no membership fees skip any month
cancel anytime and there's a 100%
satisfaction guarantee so you will not
pay for a bottle you don't like and for
a limited time you can get 20 bucks off
when you go to try wink comm slash
Pakman that's t ry wi and c comm forward
slash Pakman for $20 off check it out